good evening thousands are still trying
to flee afghanistan days after the
taliban takeover and many are trying to
come to the united states thanks for
joining us tonight at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis the afghan
community in las vegas and local
nonprofits are getting ready to help
orco mana joins us live with their
message tonight orco
well brian and denise you're seeing
images just like this one come out of
afghanistan thousands of people trying
to leave the country now most people in
las vegas afghan community have family
that are still in afghanistan they just
want to see their loved ones be safe and
they as well as catholic charities are
ready to welcome them to nevada
every secondary agreement will happen
surrounded by the colorful clothing at
taj boutique in las vegas malalai
kawastani is trying to focus on work but
she can't stop thinking about the
taliban takeover of afghanistan her home
country all of them they are scared of
their life you know they don't know
what's going to bring tomorrow kohistani
is an afghan refugee who came to las
vegas around the age of 14. her brother
and his family are still in
afghanistan's capital city of kabul now
caught in the chaos now is the time that
we want him to come at least they all be
safe as crowds filled the airport in
kabul trying to flee the country
koistani wants the silver state to open
its arms we can help everyone
so everyone has the right to live a life
of freedom catholic charities says it's
unclear how many refugees will come to
nevada but they estimate about 500 could
arrive within the next year so they're
preparing part of the services that we
provide to them upon arrival
is food clothing and shelter originally
covering those basic necessities and
then after that they're eligible for
resettlement services for up to five
years koistani tells me the whole afghan
community in las vegas is also ready to
step up and take care of their own
anything we can do will do
now several states across the country
have offered to take in afghan refugees
nevada governor steve sisolak has not
made any current remarks in response to
the situation right now but he has been
an outspoken advocate for refugees in
the past reporting live tonight orca
mana 8 news now